un día de negro otro de blanco en
Colombia el carnaval de negros y blancos
es un momento de mezcla cultural para
celebrar la liberación de los Esclavos
así como la unidad es una de las fiestas
más importantes del país ofrece un
espectáculo colorido el festival se
celebra cada mes de enero y atrae a
miles de personas a las calles de San
Juan de pasto en el sur de Colombia
salimos en familia y lo que hacemos Es
disfrutar
esto es una fiesta inclusiva
es reconociendo toda nuestra cultura y
nuestros ancestros bueno Nosotros
siempre estos carnavales los utilizamos
para divertirnos para iniciar un año
nuevo con alegría con entusiasmo con
mucha esperanza este Carnaval que
funciona las tradiciones española
africana indígena de Colombia pretende
contribuir a romper las fronteras
raciales y ayudar a derribar Las
barreras culturales de ahí el nombre de
blanco negro de los dos últimos días del
carnaval durante el primer día los
blancos se pintan la cara de negro para
celebrar la liberación de los Esclavos y
al día siguiente todo se visten y se
maquillan de blanco tolerancia y
respecto son los valores que quiere
transmitir esta fiesta declarada
patrimonio de la humanidad por la UNESCO